Matt Miller the storm is a lesser storm
but nevertheless outside of new york and
north it's serious what have you
observed this morning well you know what
actually roads here are pretty clear
they've already cleared off the platform
here although the metro-north is not
running and won't be running for the
foreseeable future today they are still
running tests trains and work trains the
tracks are not covered in snow so to me
it honestly as a kid from Ohio growing
up the 70s it snowed a lot and it was
normal in the winter like a freak
occurrence that's good man I didn't stop
our lives one more question here very
important how many coyotes died to make
that hood on your on your coat I think
I'm pretty sure they were factory raised
coyotes and probably treated very kindly
you know what we're gonna do Todd we're
gonna drive around this morning and see
and see how things look I'm going to go
and pick up Stephanie ruhle right now
because she's stuck down in or is it
cool people live right back at not
Chelsea it's Tribeca she's stuck down in
Tribeca and she can't get an uber
believe it or not so we're gonna go down
and pick her up I got a three and a half
pound box of peanut butter filled
pretzels from costco last night when I
was stocking up with my doom prepper
supplies and we're gonna see if we can
deliver her to the bloomberg building by
the time market maker starts no question
even here in New York City Brendan
really there was a real run on
foodstuffs oh there was ice are you
kidding i was out I'm we live on Long
Island I bought candles last night
deeply embarrassed that I want to get
paid wage what I bought shovels for the
gay roommate man I just want to ask you
a favor my family's in Nassau County
right now could you get word to them
that I'm safe no problem I can drive
over there we can get anywhere it's no
problem i'm in the woods equally here
well good Matt Miller thank you so much
for bronxville New York